Moin Leute, da bin ich wieder.
Heckfield.
Nennen wir es doch auch mal so.
Ja.
Ich hab grad versucht ein Video aufzunehmen.
Weil
die letzten Male wo ich das gestreamt hab
war ja total auf die Frage
so lohnt sich das Game jetzt endlich oder so.
Ich hab grad versucht ein Video dazu aufzunehmen
und ich hab auch, ich hab
quasi fast zwölf Minuten drüber
geschwätzt, aber so wirklich
gefallen hat mir das Video
nicht.
Gammelfield. Das find ich fast noch
besser.
Gammelfield 2042.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt.
Das hat mir
das Video hat mir nicht so wirklich gefallen.
Ich glaube
ich lass es echt gut sein mit Videos
zu dem Game. Ich meine im Endeffekt
was willst du machen?
Das Game juckt ja eh keinen mehr.
Außer
Außer noch so ein paar
Boomer Gamer wie mich.
Wobei, naja.
Mich auch nur noch am
Rande. Aber es macht ab und zu mal für ein paar Runden
doch noch Bock.
Aber es ist einfach kein gutes Game.
Immer noch nicht.
Und wirds auch nicht. Ich meine wir müssen uns mal überlegen.
Wir haben
20 Monate jetzt
an dem Game rumgebaut. Ja.
Und eigentlich hat sich
grundlegend nichts geändert.
Es wurden halt so ein paar Sachen
die man einfach umsetzen kann umgesetzt.
Aber ansonsten die Maps sind immer noch
die eingebauten Maps sind trotz Überarbeitung
immer noch naja.
Ich meine man mag es kaum glauben
aber das Game ist 20 Monate alt.
Ziemlich genau.
Aber seh mal ehrlich Leute.
Es juckt auch keinen mehr.
Wie gesagt. Außer noch so ein paar Battlefield Boomer
wie mich.
Und anscheinend manche von euch noch.
Ich hab jetzt ja so
ein paar Runden gestreamt und
da kam auch immer die Frage so.
Und wie ist das Game jetzt?
Zumal nächstes Jahr angeblich
ja schon das nächste Battlefield kommen soll.
Also wenn man mal
den Gerüchten glaubt.
Könnte ich mir aber durchaus vorstellen.
Aber ich hab da keine Hoffnung.
Also ich setze
in das nächste Battlefield echt keine Hoffnung mehr.
Weil du kannst eigentlich
mit der Einstellung kannst du eigentlich nur
gewinnen.
Weil entweder kannst du sagen ey Leute ich hab recht
behalten.
Also ich hab recht behalten.
Ich wusste Bescheid.
Oder
naja
auf gehts. Oder man wird positiv überrascht.
Aber ich glaube nicht dass man positiv überrascht wird.
Ich meine
die haben schon ein paar Sachen
mittlerweile ganz brauchbar hinbekommen.
Und zwar dass sie alten Content
in die normale Playlist reingepatcht haben.
Es gibt jetzt
alte Maps wie Erika Harbour,
Valparaiso und auch Sharkandals in Rush.
Letztens hatten wir auch
eine übelst gute Valparaiso Runde.
33-2 oder sowas.
Richtig 39-jähriger
Boomer Basht Junge Triads. Da ging es richtig durch.
Aber
ganz im Ernst selbst das Einfügen
alter Maps hat ja auch nur sehr halbherzig
funktioniert in dem Game.
In Valparaiso
kannst du durch nix mehr durchschießen.
Selbst die dünnsten Bretter sind massive
Wände
dafür. Selbst
für LMGs und alles kannst du nicht
durchschießen.
Nosharkandals ist verbuggt.
Nosharkandals respawnen die Attacker Boote nicht richtig.
Also wenn der erste Push
in die Hose geht, war es das.
Komplett.
Es ist auch sehr halbherzig umgesetzt.
Sprich die haben den Kram
zwar importiert,
aber die haben es halt überhaupt nicht ordentlich angepasst.
Du kannst
auch
ich finde auch Caspian Border spielt sich in Battlefield 2042
nicht so gut wie im Original.
Letztendlich steht das
alles irgendwie sinnbildlich
für das ganze Game. Von Anfang an.
Das Game ist teilweise
gut gedacht,
aber nicht richtig
durchdacht und auch
oftmals schlampig umgesetzt.
Map Reworks haben kaum geholfen.
Ja.
Die haben halt hauptsächlich Kisten und Sandsäcke hingestellt
und haben gesagt, nice rework, GG Eats.
Ich meine es gibt die ein oder anderen Änderungen,
die ich ganz cool finde.
Und wenn ich sage,
dass ich das ganz cool finde, dann meine ich,
dass sie das
im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten
ganz gut gemacht haben.
Zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel die Vault Waffen.
Oder auch die Vault Waffen
mit den Attachments, also die Waffen aus den alten
Teilen. Das ist wirklich gut.
Da gibt es wenigstens ein bisschen Variation jetzt.
Das gab es ja im Release, war ja der Waffenbildschirm
quasi nackig.
Hast ja mehr oder weniger
planke UI drunter gesehen. Mittlerweile musst du
mal zumindest ein bisschen scrollen, wenn du dir die
Waffen anguckst. Also das mit den Vault Waffen
finde ich gut. Das Attachments aus den
alten Teilen finde ich auch ganz gut.
Alte Maps finde ich
auch gut, ja.
Und dass es jetzt wieder sowas wie
wie Klassen gibt.
Aber trotzdem ist das Game immer noch
Battlefield Lite, ja. Also und das
mit den Klassen,
ist ja auch nur zur Hälfte, zur Hälfte wahr.
Die Specialist gibt es ja immer noch. Es hat sich ja nicht so
viel geändert.
Vor allem, die brauchen, die brauchen
echt mega
lang alles umzusetzen.
Die Maps, die ausgeliefert
wurden, waren zum größten Teil komplett
Schrott.
Und die haben jetzt, muss man sich mal vorstellen,
die haben jetzt 20, ja habe ich schon
gesehen, die haben jetzt 20 Monate
immer noch
nicht alle Maps überarbeitet.
Ich meine,
bald soll ja Hourglass kommen,
glaube ich, als letzte überarbeitete
Map. Aber selbst
mit den Überarbeitungen sind die
Maps, mit denen das Spiel
ausgeliefert wurde halt zum größten Teil
ja
geht so. Also
zwei Drittel der Maps spiele ich nicht gerne
und vor dem einen Drittel
würde ich sagen, ja geht so
und
ein paar vielleicht so. Moneyfest mag
ich in Rush ganz gern zum Beispiel.
Aber würde ich sagen, oh ja
und allerdings hier
wie heißt die Map mit dem Schiff?
Nicht Discarded, die
DLC Map, hab ich wieder vergessen.
Die finde ich auch nicht schlecht zum Beispiel.
Zumal
die Überarbeitung von den Maps
ja zu 90 Prozent, hatten wir es ja gerade
von, zu 90 Prozent ist die
Überarbeit, ja ja genau,
gestrandet, die meine ich.
Und die Überarbeitung ist ja zu 90
Prozent auch nur Sunset und Container
gewesen, die hingestellt wurden. Also man hat sich da
gar keine richtige Mühe gegeben. Das ist so
wirklich Level
Design
auf Sparflamme, anders kann man das nicht nennen.
Also wisst ihr,
ich glaube, was man ganz gut sagen kann ist,
wenn sie ein
Release für Ende des
Jahres 2023 anstreben
würden und sich jetzt nochmal,
wenn sich die Schweben jetzt nochmal so voll reinhängen
und auch vielleicht so ein bisschen
auf das Feedback
aus dem
20 monatigen Playtest
sich angucken,
dann könnte das ein ganz guter Launch Ende
2023 werden.
Das Problem ist nur, dass das Release
halt vor eineinhalb Jahren gewesen ist.
Also würden die das jetzt Ende
des Jahres rausbringen, würde ich sagen, okay
wenn ihr euch nochmal richtig
reinhängt, dann könnte das was werden.
Meine Specialists sind auch noch da.
Sie haben jetzt die Specialists
eingeteilt in klassische
Battlefield-Klassen.
Allerdings wirklich viel geändert hat sich das nicht.
Man hatte so ein paar Beschränkungen.
Du kannst jetzt nicht mehr,
ich glaube, kann jetzt nicht mehr jeder das Medikit mitnehmen
und solche Geschichten.
Engineers haben beispielsweise
jetzt einen passiven Skill,
dass man mit LMGs, warum eigentlich LMGs?
Warum haben Engineers eigentlich nicht
SMGs wiedergekriegt?
Also Engineers können ja mit LMGs
jetzt genauer schießen.
Aber selbst das
bekommen sie ja nicht richtig hin.
Guckt euch
das mal aktuell an mit Dozer,
nicht Boris, der Typ, wo ich immer denke, dass es Boris ist,
aber es ist Dozer.
Der mit dem Schild.
Das ist richtig die Pest gerade.
Der Typ rennt irgendwie seit ein paar Patches schneller,
schlägt schneller, macht
AE-Schaden mit seinem One-Hit-Schild,
ohne es kaum zu treffen.
Ihr werdet es gleich sehen, wenn wir ein paar Runden spielen,
das ist abfuck.
Und das dauert wieder Monate und Jahre,
irgendwie so das zu fixen, oder Wochen.
Ah, Mann, ich weiß nicht.
Deswegen habe ich halt auch keine Hoffnung in das nächste Battlefield.
Ich hätte,
wir sind mittlerweile soweit,
ich hätte mehr Hoffnung in das nächste Battlefield,
was ja so geleaked 2 für 2024
wurde, ob das jetzt stimmt,
zweimal dahingestellt, keine Ahnung.
Ich hätte mehr Hoffnung darin, wenn es nicht DICE
machen würde, ohne Scheiß.
DICE ist sich einfach zu,
hat man aber 2042 gesehen,
zu selbstsicher und zu unfähig
zugleich.
Und ich hätte fast
ein besseres Gefühl, wenn ein anderer Hersteller das machen würde.
Man hat es die letzten Teile
schon gesehen, aber 2042 war der absolute
Gipfel. Natürlich kann man sagen, ja,
DICE ist an mich alleine dran schuld,
das stimmt wohl. Sicherlich haben da
viele EA-Entscheidungen auch mit dazu beigetragen,
aber DICE hat den Kram
designt und quasi auch so gepitcht
und die waren dafür
verantwortlich, da auch mal was ordentliches zu
implementieren und zu zeigen. Ich glaube, die können es
einfach nicht mehr. Das ist Battlefield 1,
Battlefield 1-Menü-Soundtrack,
der im Hintergrund läuft.
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch das mal
angucken. Erstmal haben sie lange über Legacy-Features
rumdiskutiert und jetzt
mittlerweile, nach 20 Monaten
oder so, kannst du endlich mal einen Squad
erstellen und ordentlich bei den Squads reinwechseln.
Ja, nice
Legacy-Feature, aber Teams
wechseln geht meines Wissens nach immer noch nicht.
Ihr könnt mich eines Besseren belehren,
Chat, geht mittlerweile Teams wechseln?
Ich glaube nicht,
weil wo kämen wir da auch hin, wenn einfach
die Leute das spielen können, worauf sie Bock haben?
Ja, das, sicherlich haben die
da auch Termindruck gemacht,
aber die Design-Anscheinungen,
die grundlegenden Design-Anscheinungen, die wir
DICE zum größten Teil getroffen haben,
weil, man muss sagen, selbst das Game,
was es jetzt ist, ist immer noch kein gutes
Battlefield.
Also selbst das wäre nicht
geil gewesen.
Ja, ja, ich will nicht sagen,
dass DICE alleine und EA,
genau, ich will auch nicht sagen, dass nur EA
dran schuld ist, weil das wird's nicht sein.
Ja, genau, solche Dinger,
der Spread,
der Spread ist auch immer noch kaputt und solche
Geschichten.
Ja, wie gesagt, dass man auch nicht mal,
ja, ja, das ist jetzt neu, es gibt jetzt hier
Content-Warning, weil das Spiel ab 18 ist oder ab 16.
Naja, und, wie gesagt,
Teams wechseln geht immer noch nicht.
Also meines Wissens
nach nicht. Und das verstehe ich halt nicht.
Warum kann ich nicht sagen,
oh, ich hab keinen Bock jetzt, sagen wir mal,
Discarded Defender
zu spielen, lasst mich doch mal switchen am Anfang
der Runde auf
Attacker. Weil, wo kämen wir dahin,
wenn wir die Leute einfach das spielen können, worauf sie
Bock haben? Es ist ja auch nicht so, als würde
ich einem was wegnehmen, am Anfang müssen die
erst mal Matchmaking auffüllen
und hast du nicht gesehen. Warum kann ich
nicht sagen, hier, ich präfere hier als Attacker zu
spielen. Ja, das würde Arbeit machen in der Implementierung,
aber die Leute könnten all das spielen, worauf sie
Bock haben.
Und dann, das hab ich ja noch gar nicht,
hab ich ja noch gar nicht erwähnt jetzt,
und dann hat DICE ja auch wieder richtig
einen draufgesetzt letzte Season,
denn,
ihr erinnert euch, ja, ich war auch sehr verwirrt
im Stream, als ich die ersten Male
Assault, oder eigentlich immer noch, Assault Rifle
gespielt habe. In der letzten Season
haben sie alle Assault Rifles
gepatcht. Nur Assault Rifles, wohlgemerkt.
Keine andere Waffenkategorie,
nur Assault Rifles. Als quasi
ein Playtest im Livepatch, sozusagen.
Und die Idee dahinter
finde ich ja nicht verkehrt,
sie wollen fördern, dass
die Leute mehr Burst schießen,
mit Assault Rifles.
Ist halt ein bisschen doof, wenn man das nur für Assault Rifles
macht und alle anderen nicht Burst, aber ist in Ordnung.
Den Ansatz verstehe ich ja noch irgendwie.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur,
dass sie das auch verbackt rausgebracht
haben und dass der Spread sich
zwischen den Bursts nicht richtig resetet.
Ich bin fast durch, ich hab's erst nicht
gecheckt, warum da Kugeln durchfliegen und sowas
durch die Gegner. Die Bursts resetten sich nicht,
das spielt sich furchtbar weird.
Wir werden jetzt gleich sehen, ob das immer noch so schlimm ist,
aber alle, allem Anschein nach, ja.
Und die, die probieren
den Kram einfach vorher nicht richtig aus.
Dazu kommt, dass ich letztens ein Video
auf YouTube gesehen hab, die das etwas genauer
analysiert haben mit diesen Bursts, und zwar
ist es noch von Waffe zu Waffe
unterschiedlich. Also die, die eigentliche
Mechanic ist noch nicht mal einheitlich implementiert.
Bei manchen resettet sich, manche werden
auch genauer, umso mehr man schießt und sowas
ganz, ganz weird.
Also ich mag
die Map, die Map in Rush mag ich
tatsächlich nicht.
Generell haben sie Rush ein bisschen verschlimmbessert.
Die M, ja klar, also generelle,
generelle, ähm
M-Complacement
ist jetzt besser als ganz am Anfang.
Du hast jetzt nicht mehr so Dinger wie
Orbital, wo das Ding auf dem Dach ist und sowas.
Wobei ich es cool fand, dass man mit dem
mit dem Hovercraft die Wand hochfahren kann.
Ich finde, das hätten sie drin lassen sollen.
Aber das M-Complacement ist jetzt
zwar anders, aber auch oftmals nicht wirklich besser.
Mir fehlt zum Beispiel auf Manifest
die letzte Base auf dem Berg und sowas
in der Richtung. Und eine Sache
ist auch noch, es dauert immer noch
total lang zwischen den ganzen Runden.
Du musst, du musst dir immer diesen ganzen
Müll angucken, Scoreboard angucken,
das Outro-Gelaber angucken.
Da musst du dir die Highlights der Runde
angucken und wer irgendwie wie
viele Revives hat und sowas, was dich überhaupt
nicht die Bohne juckt, ja. Dann kommt
Battle Pass Progression,
Unlocked Progression, nebenbei startet Matchmaking.
Du wartest ewig.
Die Runde ist vorbei, also vom
Zeitpunkt, wo du die Kontrolle über deine Figur
verlierst, bis du wirklich wieder
spielen kannst, dauert. Dann startet,
dann lädt die neue Runde rein. Dann hast du erstmal
Pre-Lobby, die irgendwie runterzählt.
Dann musst du erstmal reinspawnen. Das dauert
zwei, drei Minuten, wo du keine
Kontrolle hast. Das ist einfach nervig. Warum dauert
das so lang? Naja.
Und eine Sache, die ich auch in den alten
Battlefield-Games immer nice gefunden hab, ist,
dass man auf den
Servern so ein bisschen Teamplay mit
Randoms hatte. Man war zufällig
mit Leuten im Squad. Es lief ganz
gut. Und
die Server haben ja auch versucht, immer die Leute,
also die Squads, nach den Runden bestehen zu lassen.
Also es gab ja so ein Setting hier. Also wenn du
einen Server gehostet hast, konntest du ja sagen, hier,
try to keep squads together oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie das hieß. Zumindest,
wenn Leute ganz gut zusammengespielt haben,
so randommäßig, ohne Freundesliste,
ohne alles, dann konntest du mit
denen auch, solange es gut lief, ein paar Runden
zusammenspielen und bist im Squad zusammengeblieben.
Das fand ich cool. So ohne Freundesliste und alles.
Aber das geht ja dank hartem
Matchmaking auch nicht mehr. Und Portal kannst du
auch nicht spielen, weil Portal
ist komplett dead. Von Hazard Zone
muss man gar nicht reden. Hazard Zone ist auch komplett
dead.
Dafür waren die Maps aus den
letzten paar Seasons ganz gut.
Mir persönlich gefällt die Season 5 Map in Rush
nicht sonderlich gut, aber ich habe eben schon im Chat gelesen.
Einige finden es sehr nice.
Die neueren Maps sind tatsächlich
ein bisschen besser. Und obwohl die ein bisschen an
Savat erinnert, aus Battlefield 4, die letzte
Season Map.
Sechste Season soll es ja auch geben, ist ja schon
bestätigt. Dann ohne neuen
Specialist und wahrscheinlich mit Map
und so. Infantry only.
Es gibt jetzt eine Playlist, die wohl
irgendwie mehr Infanterielastig ist.
Irgendwas in der Richtung habe ich glaube
gesehen. Naja, lange
Rede kurzer Sinn Leute. Ich denke,
weil ja die Frage immer kam, auch die letzten
Streams, ob sich das Game jetzt lohnt.
Also ich denke, weiß nicht, also zum
Vollpreis, würde ich sagen
nee, lohnt sich nicht.
Im Sale für 15, 20
Euro kann man sich vielleicht mal überlegen.
Aber auch nur, wenn man
unbedingt halt mal wieder echt so ein paar Runden Battlefield
braucht und das nicht
und diese paar Runden nicht absolvieren möchte
in einem Battlefield, was man schon besitzt.
Für 15 Euro kann man übrigens aktuell auch
Battlebit. Für 15
Euro kann man auch Battlebit Remastered
unterstützen, was ja viele Leute zur Zeit
voll abfeiern. Ich glaube nicht,
dass es der nächste krasse Battlefield-Killer wird.
Das macht, das macht
DICE alleine schon.
Das muss kein anderes
Game machen.
Ich war noch ein bisschen
skeptisch, aber wie gesagt,
DICE killt das schon. Wow, Alter, warum ist das so groß?
Killt das
schon alleine? Können wir uns auch
demnächst mal im Stream angucken?
Enemy Territory?
Ja, aber das habe ich vor
15 Jahren oder so mal gespielt.
Naja.
Allerdings, okay, letzter Satz
dazu. Wenn ihr das Game jetzt vielleicht
wirklich schon gekauft habt zu Release, eventuell
sogar irgendeine überteuerte Edition gekauft
habt zu Release,
dann lohnt es sich natürlich
schon mal reinzuschauen, weil
dank der aktuellen Season gibt es
halbwegs große Playerbase. Gucken wir
mal kurz, Steam Stats,
BF202042.
Ja.
Ja, geht doch, geht doch eigentlich
ganz gut. Meine ist natürlich auch schon wieder gefallen,
dass es immer noch Season Start ist. Also
aktuell kann man wenigstens halbwegs, halbwegs
spielen. Ja, dann kann man noch mal
reingucken. Aber für alle
anderen, ernsthaft würde ich sagen,
vergesst das Game und spielt lieber was anderes.
Es gibt ja aktuell genug gute Games, wo man ein bisschen
reinsuchten kann. Es gibt
leider nichts, was Battlefield komplett ersetzen kann.
Aber
also jetzt da noch
einzusteigen ist, glaube ich,
als Game auch einfach nicht
gut genug.
Und wer weiß, vielleicht kommt ja irgendwann
noch mal echt ein gescheites Battlefield Game raus.
Am besten nicht von DICE,
von irgendeinem Studio,
was Bock hat und weiß, was
da macht. Eventuell tut
sich bei DICE auch was. Wer ist jetzt der
Apex-Chef am Start?
Also der ehemalige Apex-Chef.
Vielleicht
kann der da noch irgendwas rumreißen,
aber ich hab halt echt keine Hoffnung. Selbst
wenn da stimmt, dass 2042 ein neues
Battlefield rauskommt, äh
2024 ein neues Battlefield rauskommen soll.
Squad habe ich mir tatsächlich
auch schon überlegt, aber Squad ist mir
zu sehr Simulation.
So wie ich Battlefield spiele,
gerade Rush Battlefield kannst du Squad
halt nicht spielen.
Das ist ein ganz anderes
Game-Gefühl. Also Scattered Loose
weiß ich nicht, hab ich nicht gespielt, aber Squad
ist schon deutlich mehr, also mehr
Armor als Battlefield.
Ja.
Ja ist es auch, ist es auch.
Ich finde Battlefield hat immer eine super
Kombination gehabt. Battlefield war casual,
du konntest das spielen, du konntest das mit deinen
Freunden spielen, du konntest das mit Leuten, die übelst gesagt
haben spielen. Da gab's Leute, die haben dann gerne
äh Sofla, Sofla am Heli-Team
gemacht oder irgendwie
äh Panzer gefahren, repariert und so.
Du konntest das eigentlich immer noch ganz, ganz gut,
ganz gut spielen. Auch Leute, die nix auf die Reihe
bekommen haben, konnten früher auch recht viel
Spaß in Battlefield haben. Du konntest aber auch,
wenn dich ein bisschen mit dem Spiel auseinandergesetzt hast,
mega krasse Runden haben. Guck dir Hexe oder, guck dir
die Hexe oder, oder äh an
oder, oder der Heap, mit dem wir letztens
zusammen gespielt haben, wie der Heli geflogen ist und so.
Also Battlefield hat sich zumindest früher immer noch
halbwegs ausgezahlt, sich ein bisschen mit dem Game
beschäftigen. Das war, fand ich schon immer
eine gute Mischung aus. Du konntest
das relativ Hardcore spielen, aber auch
übelst Casual und trotzdem hat's Spaß gemacht. Und das
ohne Skill-Based Matchmaking
oder irgend so'n Shit.
Ja.
Deswegen, ich glaube, wenn DICE das nächste
Battlefield macht, ist R.I.P.
Oder halt, oder halt sie haben DICE so umgecampelt,
dass es, dass es jetzt besser funktioniert.
Mal gespannt.
Leute, ich hab übrigens ein bisschen was
an den Stream-Settings geändert.
Ihr müsst mir mal sagen, ob das jetzt besser aussieht gleich.
Ich habe, ich mach mal
kurz in meiner Vorschau Fullscreen,
weil der statische Desktop sieht selbstverständlich
ganz gut aus. So.
Und zwar, wir lassen übrigens
mal die Battlefield Menü-Musik an,
weil das Spiel hat keine gescheite Musik.
Da ist die Battlefield 1
Menü-Musik einfach besser.
Also.
Ich hab ein bisschen was umgestellt
an meinen Settings
für, für den
Stream.
Mal gucken. Also angeblich soll es
in Bewegung jetzt deutlich smoother
aussehen. Guck, es gibt
jetzt Infantry-Breakthrough.
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren, Infantry-Breakthrough?
Anstatt Rush?
Ne, wir spielen mal eine Runde Rush.
Und ich muss
mir mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm angucken,
wie das jetzt, wie das jetzt aussieht
im, im,
im Stream. Ich werd das,
das sehen wir ja gleich schon beim Reinspawnen.
Was spielen wir? Erica Harbor
Defense. Okay. Perfekt.
Perfekt zum testen,
wie die, wie die,
wie die Video-Quality jetzt ist.
Oh. Ich renn jetzt,
nicht wundern, ich werd jetzt gleich sinnlos rumrennen.
So wie
immer also. Oh, wir sind
schon zweite Base. Und mal gucken, wie
die, naja, es pixelt immer noch
ein bisschen, gell?
Aber gut, ich hab halt nur 7900 Bitrate.
Da kannst du halt nix...
Es sieht aber
okay aus für Bewegung, muss man sagen.
Es ist echt in Ordnung.
Ich mein,
ich guck jetzt hier gerade auf
den zweiten Bildschirm. Ich mein,
es ist halt 7900 Bitrate.
Da kannst du jetzt kein super krass
gestochen, scharf
Bild erwarten. Aber es
geht doch echt klar.
Lautstärke ist, ist Lautstärke
okay, Chatge?
Ich glaub, ein bisschen laut, gell?
Ist nicht der Trick, dass man
906... Doch, aber da
hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also, wenn die Gegner gescheit sind, flanken die halt
hier außen rum. Und das vermute ich auch mal, dass die das machen.
Ach, guck mal da.
Was ist da los?
Was ist da los? Richtig
PP-ge-aimt.
Aber erstmal hier kurz
Spritze in den Arm.
Oh, von wo? Hinter mir, Alter!
Es ist in Battlefield immer den, den du nicht siehst.
Ich glaub, es ist ein Ticken laut. Ich mach mal kurz hier
paar, paar kleine Sachen runter
und, und, und ich muss die, die Musik,
die Hintergrundmusik ausmachen. Das irritiert mich.
Hintergrundmusik irritiert mich.
Oh, die sind schon fast durch. Da müssen wir uns jetzt
einfach mal beeilen. Ich glaube, die, die,
guck mal, die, ja, die sind alle vorne
und gleich machen die Legehennen an.
Ah, und keiner kriegt's mit.
Seid ihr noch da? Hier vorne war,
war nicht hier grad was?
Wo denn?
Gegenüber!
Hier, hier, hier.
Ich bin, ich weiß es nicht. Entweder kommt er hier rein.
Ich bräuchte so
einen Motion-Sensor.
Ich geh mal kurz so unten das M-Com checken.
Ich bräuchte
so einen Motion-Sensor. Das wär jetzt echt praktisch.
Wir machen mal,
wir machen mal full, full objective, Leute.
Full, full objective play.
Mal kurz gucken, was
da hinten so abgeht noch.
Alter, Doser,
Doser, Mann. Warum rennt man hier mit dem Schild rum?
Ist total pp-ger.
Ist der auf dem Dach?
Ha!
Guck, der hat einen weggeboxt. Das ist so op
mit dem Schild zur Zeit.
Das ist nicht mehr normal.
Okay, ich bin unschlüssig.
Irgendjemand schneibert auf mich.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut, ist ja gut.
Okay.
Ich campe hier jetzt rum.
Wir machen jetzt
hyper objective play.
Dann ist nämlich die Runde bald vorbei.
Weil ich hab
ehrlich gesagt null Bock auf Eureka-Harbour-Defense.
Okay, passt mal auf.
Wow! What the?
Ich diffuse, ich mach mal
mit diffuse, gell? Weil man immer nicht weiß,
ob der Dude jetzt nicht gleich stirbt.
Zurück vom Essen.
Captain Poggers, bist du am Start? Max, willst du auch mitmachen?
Wenn ihr wollt,
können wir eine Runde spielen.
Also, wenn ihr wollt, können wir eine Runde spielen.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Was ist hier los?
Game,
darf ich mich heilen?
Game, ist das möglich?
Und warum hat es mich gerade
abgefackelt durch die Wand, Alter?
Okay.
Ist hier was?
Wow, wow, wow.
Daneben, Alter!
Da hätte ich es jetzt nicht mit vermutet, okay.
Noch schnell kacken.
Good luck, have fun.
Oh, Poo-Poo-Time.
Oh, es wird geschneit auf mich.
Geschneit!
So, nächste Runde Attacker, please.
Da muss ich nicht so langweiliges
im Kreisrennen ums M-Com machen.
Noch neun Tickets.
Easy.
Alter, von wo?
Wo sind die Dudes alle? Ich seh die nicht mal.
Okay, hier kommt anscheinend nichts mehr.
Ich glaub, das war's jetzt.
Können wir noch einmal rauspushen und was killen?
Achja, haben wir nicht
irgendwie sogar Attachments für das Ding?
Oha.
Hier ist doch bestimmt was drinnen.
Fuck!
Das waren zwei.
Aber easy win.
Okay, jetzt Attacker, please.
Gute Map und Attacker, please.
Attacker, please.
Übrigens, was auch toll ist,
was sehr nett ist von DICE,
DICE hat mitgedacht,
und zwar, man darf jetzt
nicht aus dem Spiel raus, man kann das Spiel
an dieser Stelle nur Alt-F4 beenden.
Die haben sich gedacht,
wer möchte denn bitteschön schon, wenn diese
coolen Outros kommen und diese geilen
Sprüche von den Specialists,
wer möchte da vielleicht schon
irgendwie raus
oder so. Und was es jetzt lädt,
weiß man auch nicht so genau. Ah, das Menü wahrscheinlich.
Okay, Social.
Serious Max, da ist er.
Invite.
Was macht unser HeliPro?
Ist der am Start?
Guck mal kurz.
Ich muss mich mal kurz ausmalen.
Ich will keine Private Messages
leaken.
Okay.
Okay, dann spielen wir schon eine Runde.
Wir spielen schon eine Runde.
Max, bist du drin?
Man erkennt ja in dem Menü nicht wirklich was.
Nee, der ist nicht drin.
Nee, nee, du hast nicht angenommen.
Ist kaputt.
Alter, warum ist dieses Spiel so broken?
Warum funktioniert fucking Party Invite nicht?
Warum ist das so kaputt, man?
Wie kriegt man das hin im Jahr
2022?
Nee, 2021 kam das raus.
Mach nochmal, okay.
Invite.
Perks as intended.
Ja, und? Ging jetzt?
Nee, geht nicht.
Okay, Leave Party.
Probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Jetzt?
Wrong Version?
What?
Okay, gab's ein Update gerade? Ich start nochmal neu.
Nee, oder?
Nee, gab kein Update.
Alter, das Game ist so kaputt, immer noch.
Das ist der absolute Wahnsinn, wie man die
einfachsten Sachen nicht hinbekommen kann.
Wichtiger Omega Keg.
Hyper Omega Keg.
Aber immerhin haben sie
RGB Support für meine Tastatur.
Die flimmert nämlich im Ladebildschirm.
So wie Battlefield halt so flimmert.
Okay.
Invite.
Präge.
Party Invite send nach 5 Minuten.
Vielleicht geht's jetzt.
Chat, habt ihr irgendwas gemerkt an den
Settings, die ich umgestellt hab?
Für
in Bewegung, Motion
Bewegungsqualität beim Gameplay
und sowas? Oder sah das
genauso aus wie das letzte Mal?
Okay, jetzt ist er ganz weg.
Jetzt ist...
Jetzt ist er komplett broken.
Jetzt ist er ganz off.
Okay, Max. Ich weiß nicht, ob das
was wird, so.
Ist das richtig los? Jetzt wirst du gar
nicht mehr angezeigt.
Das ist so kaputt, Mann.
Soll ich mal online kommen?
Soll ich mal online kommen in...
Okay, EA App.
In-Game.
Ja. So, versuch mal
mir nachzujoinen, ob du mich jetzt siehst.
Oder versuch
mir einfach mal nachzujoinen, Leute.
Siehst du mich wenigstens online?
Oh, fuck. Nee, nicht Private Open.
X Defined. Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich wollte die ganze Zeit,
aber jetzt ist, glaub ich, zu spät, oder?
Der Playtest ist vorbei.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jemals noch
ein guter Battlefield Teil erscheint, sagt der Chat.
Ja, ich hab mich am Anfang des Streams
drüber ausgelassen und ja, ich hab da auch
keine Hoffnung oder wenig,
sehr, sehr wenig Hoffnung.
Das mach ich nicht auf hier im Stream.
Okay. Es ist vom Mod-Gil.
Ich mach's auf.
Oh, ja. Obviously
Pornography.
Wrong Version.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung, was mit dem Game
wieder abgeht, Alter.
Ich...
Ich bin online. Ihr könnt einfach nachjoinen,
wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Oh, nee. Nee, nee, nee.
Valparaiso Defender. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein! Na, okay.
Ich wollte eigentlich eine Attacker-Runde spielen.
Okay.
Perf Overlay Draw FPS 1.
Keg W 46.
Oh, nee. Ist okay so.
Haben wir noch irgendwas unlockt
für das Ding bis jetzt?
No Solo Shit Out There.
No Solo Shit.
Du startest jetzt das Game?
Kannst du nach... Kannst du grad gucken,
ob du nachjoinen kannst?
Wenn nicht, nächste Runde.
Das geht hier schnell.
Ich ragequitte eh, wenn wir die erste Base nicht halten.
Vielleicht, vielleicht sollte ich...
Ach so, das geht ja nicht mehr abbrechen.
Selbstverständlich geht Spawn abbrechen nicht.
Ich wollte sagen, ich könnte ja auch mal versuchen,
als Anti eher rein zu spawnen, weil der Heli
ist eigentlich das, was sich am meisten
abfucken kann.
So.
Moin Michael, 50 Milliarden.
Heli?
Wo ist er denn?
Wow, wow.
Alter, um die Ecke, man.
Ich fass es nicht.
Reds, please.
Epic Pro 08.
Was ist mit dem Typ? Hallo?
Hallo?
Okay, ich muss als Anti
rein spawnen.
Wir machen jetzt Heli Geier.
Heli Geier.
Javelin? Nee, das Ding.
Ach, das hab ich schon.
Okay, nice. Hat sich ja richtig gelohnt.
Sehr gut.
Hallo, game.
Der flairt immer noch.
Jawohl, schön rausgegeiert,
so muss das sein.
Wir kriegen's, wir kriegen's, wir kriegen's.
Fuck it, Alter.
Wie viel ist denn da los?
Bist du nachgejoint?
Captain Poggers, wo ist der Captain Poggers?
Hier, zumindest im gleichen Team.
Okay, wir sollten
unbedingt weiter Heli geiern.
Was ist denn das für eine Waffe,
die ich hier eigentlich am Start hab?
Ist das ACR?
Was ist denn das überhaupt für ein Ding?
Ich glaub die ACR, gell?
Dann bin ich planlos, lul.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Drei Spuren, Alter.
Jetzt ist...
Es ist ja mal gut, Mann.
Dead.
Battle Bit. Ich hab's mir gekauft
vor zwei Tagen, aber ich war
schon beim letzten Playtest.
Okay, wenn du das hast,
haben die viel geändert seit dem letzten
Public Playtest?
Schön runtergammeln.
Flares raus, please, jawohl.
Dead.
Ist gleich.
Ja, dann lohnt sich's aber nicht richtig.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, so hundertprozentig
hat mich das beim letzten Playtest nicht überzeugt.
Oh, shit.
Shit, ich wollte auf den Grappling-Hook
switchen, den ich ja gar nicht mehr habe.
Ah, ich mag Defender
auf dieser Map nicht.
Zumal wir auch
richtig auf den Sack kriegen.
Okay, das Durchschießen durch die Gegner
ist immer noch da. Trotzdem
neuen Spread-Reset.
Okay, wo sind sie? Wo sind sie? Wo sind sie?
Shit, Alter.
Kannste nicht alleine machen, Alter.
Ich hab ein Poggers, bist du
wieder rausgeflogen? Nee, du bist noch da.
Ich muss Heli geiern.
Können wir sonst vergessen.
Wenn nicht einer Heli geiert, wird das nix.
So ist es halt.
Guck mal. Aha.
Ah,
fucking hell.
Da ist einer noch um die Ecke.
Komm in die Gruppe. Okay, mach ich.
In welches?
Grave-Digger. Jawohl.
Digger!
Ich spawn bei dir, Digger.
Lass mal rein, please.
Ja, auch...
Du kannst hier
übrigens nichts mehr durchschießen, durch nix.
Oh, wie
PP-Guard aimt.
Der Flugpilot.
Ultra-PP-Guard.
Wir brauchen mehr Leute
im Squad.
Ist das...
Was hab ich denn da?
Wer spielt denn sowas?
Ist das Squad Public?
Alter, die gehen da grad mal richtig ab.
Moment, auf den Konsolen gibt es
immer noch kein Scoreboard.
Ich geh jetzt mal wieder zurück
auf ordentliche Klasse, mit der man
auch was killen kann.
Ja?
Warum habt ihr immer noch kein Scoreboard auf Konsolen?
Der Anstand ist gleich.
Nicht so?
Tja.
Wir sind halt immer noch Dad-Wing.
Also hat man halt einen gescheiten Heli
als Gegner.
Oh, der Max ist am Start.
Cool, wie man nichts machen kann dagegen.
Von äußerst Porn.
Okay, vergess es, Alter.
Ich glaub, wir müssen irgendwie rüber.
Die wissen halt, dass ich hier bin.
Oh, oh, oh!
Moment, ist das diese hässliche Drohne?
Ich hab nix gesehen.
Lul.
Aber gar nix.
Okay.
Ich seh nix.
Leute, ich seh nix.
Okay, da können wir
nicht hin, sonst sind wir direkt dead.
Okay, hier oben ist
einsch ganz nice.
Kann man... Ah, shit.
Wollte gerade sagen, kann man schön abcampen.
Game!
Oh, nice!
Wir haben's defused, good.
Excellent.
Oh, da sind noch mehr.
Ich reload.
Andere Seite.
Okay.
Ich hör hier 50.000 Gegner moven.
Okay, nice.
Wo ist der Rest?
Ich bin der einzige
auf der Seite, glaub hier.
Oh, shit, shit, shit.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich bleibe auf B.
Es hat keinen Sinn, da jetzt rüber zu stelzen.
Ich find ja nett,
dass ihr so einzeln kommt.
Ich find das äußerst nett von denen,
dass die hier einzeln reingestelzt kommen.
Das ist äußerst...
Oh, ge...
Oh, oh, oh.
Max, Max, ich probier den Stuhl.
Spritze in den Kopf.
Wie im Krankenhaus.
Alter!
Ist ja mal gut, man.
Mehr Explosionen wurden nichts erkennst.
Oh, shit.
Ah, fuck.
Jetzt haben wir's verloren.
Wenn ich dead bin, ist es hier vorbei.
Ich bin der Einzige, der gerade was killt.
Ah, cool.
Please, please, please, please.
Jawohl, jawohl, jawohl.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben...
Oh, shit.
Ich seh nix.
What the fuck, Alter?
Das ist jetzt mal richtig
Battlefield-Action.
Du bist einfach instant dead.
Aber wir schlagen uns doch
ganz gut gerade.
Wenn wir Glück haben, kommen wir hier noch rein.
Eigentlich können wir noch hier rein spawnen,
wenn er mag. Ja, perfekt, perfekt, exzellent.
Easy win.
Man muss einfach
bam, bap, bap, bam.
So wie der Assi Tony das auch schon gemacht hat.
Dann klappt das auch.
Ich dowser, wenn ich das schon sehe.
Ja, das war der Heli-Typ.
Wollen wir wetten, dass das der Heli-Typ war?
Ja, 46 war der Heli-Typ.
Ist es möglich, seine FPS
ohne V-Sync zu begrenzen?
Kannst du nicht sogar
in den Options hier direkt einstellen?
Ähm, Cap?
FPS-Cap, gibt's das nicht hier sogar?
Also, ja, kannst du.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob in diesem Game direkt...
Aber ich bilde mir ein?
Wo ist denn das?
Display?
Hier, Refresh-Rate kannst du einstellen.
Oh, nee, habe ich jetzt so 24
Refresh-Rate stehen?
Ich, ich denke, ich denke ganz dringend.
Ja, ja, danke für die, für die
Erinnerung.
Pass mal auf, ich habe jetzt 24 FPS gleich.
Nochmal Defender.
Oh, nee, oh, nee.
Max, bist du rausgeflogen?
Nee.
Okay, das hat zum Glück
nicht gespeichert.
24 FPS wäre halt auch mal geil gewesen.
So, die einzige sinnvolle
Möglichkeit ist,
zum Defenden,
ist hier oben zu sein,
bevor die Gegner da sind.
Nee, Orbital Rush ist auch nicht gut.
Die meisten Maps sind nicht gut.
Fast schon wieder veraimt.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie der Schuss durchgeflogen ist?
Habt ihr's gesehen?
What the hell?
Der hat mich gerade gesniped.
Alter, von wo?
Äh, wo sind wir überhaupt?
Ah, wo sind wir denn?
Immer noch in unserer Ecke.
Spritze in den Sack.
So belebt man die Leute wieder.
Erster Hilfekurs hier.
Bildungs-FPS-Auftrag.
Das hat gehittet, lol.
Ist ja hier schon richtiger Spawn-Rape
gerade.
Egal, eine Runde muss auch mal schnell vorbei sein.
Wow.
Käpt'n Poggers.
Schneiber-Dudes, alter.
Sag mal,
die Gegner, die liegen auch nur noch in ihrem Spawn
und snybern. Das heißt, die haben im Endeffekt
schon verloren.
Oh, habt ihr meinen
PP-Scheibenwischer gesehen gerade?
Oh, oh, oh, jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen.
Die ganzen Schneiber-Dudes.
Alter, es sind ja noch mehr Schneiber.
Oh, shit.
Jetzt haben sie
wahrscheinlich unsere Stellung.
Ja, oh, fuck.
Es sind einfach alle gestorben da oben gerade.
PP-Time.
Schnell!
Na, hab ich's noch mal gesaved?
Hab ich's noch mal gesaved?
Oh, nee, leer.
Hab ich's noch mal gesaved gerade?
Sieht so aus.
Das war der einzige Schuss,
den guten Schuss, den er im Game landet.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Und er hat halt nichts,
er hat seinem Team nichts gebracht,
dass er die ganze Runde geil
geil gesnypt hat.
Achtung, Spritze in den Sack.
Die Winkel sind teilweise äußerst unglücklich,
wo ihr wiederbelebt werdet.
Der Typ sitzt immer noch da.
Der sitzt wirklich immer noch an der gleichen Stelle.
Die sind wirklich
sehr resistent,
die Schneiders hier.
Äußerst hartnäckige Schneider, Jungs.
Guckt da hinten, der hier auch.
Der da auch hier.
Vielleicht liege ich nicht im Felsen
und kann gerätst werden?
Nice.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
am Anfang von dem Game,
wo du nicht
gerätst werden konntest,
wenn du den Fuß im Felsen hattest?
Fuß im Felsen,
das ist unglaublich.
Was zur...
Der ist gar nicht schlecht.
Der Schneider, Mensch.
Der Schneider-Typ von der anderen Seite.
Okay, tot.
Ich release mal, Leute.
Kein Sinn, ich liege mit in den Granaten.
Die können aber nicht mal
viele Tickets haben.
Hier ist ein guter Spawn-Point.
Irgendwo hier ist ein Spawn-Point, jawohl.
What the fuck?
Warum hing da ein Typ
in der Luft gerade?
Eats.
So, und jetzt, please,
Attacker, please, gute Map.
So, zum Beispiel...
Valparaiso-Attacker.
Meinetwegen auch
Nosha-Kennels-Attacker,
wobei Nosha-Kennels-Attacker halt...
bugged ist.
Weil die
Attacker-Boote nicht richtig respawnen.
Manifest-Attacker,
ich nehme jede Map-Attacker.
Hauptsache Attacker, please.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, Chat,
ihr könnt eure FPS-Zahl eigentlich
hier direkt ingame
beschränken.
Ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher,
ob das hier auswirkt.
Ich hatte die ganze Zeit, dass auf 24 FPS
stehen. Es waren aber halt keine 24
FPS. Das Game ist halt
insofern auch verbuggt, dass nicht mehr das funktioniert.
Okay.
Gehen wir nochmal in die Options.
Options-Display. Ja, so ist gut.
Fullscreen.
Also ich glaube, das sollte das schon limitieren.
Was sind wir denn? Sind wir...
Och, wir sind wieder Defense.
Keck.
Wait.
Gibt keine Attacker-Runden
heute.
Exakt, ja.
239,74. So sieht's aus.
Wissenschaftlich calculated.
Aber genau, wir wissen ja,
das menschliche Auge sieht eh nicht mehr als...
Wie viel? Wie viel?
Zwölf?
24? Was war immer das Meme?
Ich glaub, 25, oder?
Das menschliche Auge kann das eh nicht...
Was bringen mehr FPS und wiederholen?
Das menschliche Auge sieht eh nicht mehr als 25 FPS.
Zwölf, weil wir zwei haben.
Ja, das hab ich immer gesagt.
Zu Meme-Zeiten, wo es noch keine
Memes gab.
Und wenn du dich auf den Kopf stellst, 48.
Guck mal!
Das ist so dumm, dass die...
Bevor die Defender überhaupt dran sein können...
Richtiger PPGA-Kram.
Und das war, Leute, das war gerade von mir,
aber sowas von...
Sekunde. Ah, ich find das Emote nicht.
Ihr wisst, was ich mein.
Ja.
Aber so krass
PPGA-Aimed.
Das war schon massive.
Mehr PPGA-Aim kommt's ja kaum noch.
Ich hätte die alle gekillt,
der andere hat nicht hingeguckt.
Hätte, ja, aber wenn man halt getroffen hätte,
dann hätte man die auch killen können.
Früher hätte man gesagt,
Commander-Krieger-Aim.
Okay, dead.
Der kann auch heute...
Weiß ich nicht, der spielt auch heute nur so komische Games,
so irgend...
Was hab ich letztens beim Krieger gesehen?
Irgend so ein komisches Jäger-Game.
So ganz weird Champ.
Irgend so ein Jäger-Game.
Naja, sowas, sowas in der Richtung.
Okay, Max hol...
What the...
Ganz schlechte Idee.
Okay, ich zeig euch die beste Defense-Position
überhaupt auf der Map,
wenn ich da hinkomm.
Die ist exzellent high IQ,
aber wir verlieren die gerade schon.
Ich hätt sie euch zeigen können,
aber leider ist es zu spät.
Beste Defense-Position ever.
Wir hatten nämlich gesehen,
wir werden richtig hart gefarmt.
Ja.
Guck mal.
Huge.
Wo sind wir denn hier gerade?
Ja klar, das hat ihn nicht gekillt.
Fuck yeah.
What the fuck, Alter.
Wir werden mega gefarmt.
Guck mal hier, wir sind einfach nur
drüber gerusht.
Oh, wir hätten aufs Dach gemusst.
Wenn wir nicht aufm Dach sind, ist Instant-Dead.
Ähm.
Es ist sehr gut, dass man unten spawnt.
Exzellent.
Exzellent ist unten spawnen.
Äh, ja, okay.
Fuck.
Nicht gesehen, durch die Tür.
Oh, der Heli-Typ hier, jetzt will er es wissen.
Jetzt komm, wir machen Heli-Flieger.
Heli-Fliege-Stelzen.
Äh.
Wo genau fliegt denn der überhaupt rum?
Wenn ich mal fragen darf.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Falsche Richtung, falsche Richtung, falsche Richtung.
PP, gar Aim,
aber ich komm nicht durch.
Ist der unter uns?
Das dumme ist halt auch, du erkennst
in dem Game nicht, wer oben
und wer unten ist in den Häusern.
Deswegen ist mir das ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu viel
Vertikalität.
Wow.
Mein Reload war noch nicht durch.
Unter uns, unter uns.
Glaub ich.
Okay.
Alter.
Das war auch PP,
gar Aim, aber immerhin
hat es gereicht.
Auf 34, jawoll.
Oh, da ist einer.
Ah, shit, noch einer.
Nicht gesehen. Lege Heli.
Strasse, wie steril das Game aussieht, ja.
Das hatten keine Details auf den Maps.
Der liegt übrigens noch hier dahinter, Leute.
Leute, pass auf, pass auf,
der liegt noch dahinter.
Okay.
Diffuske, Diffuske, Diffuske.
Oh.
Wo ist hier was?
Oh, Game, please.
Boris.
Ich hör die Battlefield-Action,
ja, aber wenn hier so richtig die Fetzen
fliegen, dann ist das
bisschen Battlefield-Feeling schon da.
Aber es könnte
halt so viel besser sein.
Darf ich mal fragen, ob überhaupt
in meinem Team jemand was killt, außer ich?
Guckt sich das mal an.
Also, mein Team ist ja nicht da.
Die Medics in meinem Team sind nicht dafür da.
Die machen schon das extremely
nice. Aber so der Rest vielleicht.
Ich campe.
Ich campe am M-Com.
Ist das Matchmaking-Prog?
Also, eben ging es gerade noch.
Oh, shit.
Fuck, Alter.
Wie hat der jetzt gehittet?
So gut wie um die Ecke.
Jetzt ist dead.
Weg.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben...
Oh, das ist der Pepega-Aimed.
Kann man nichts machen.
Also, bei mir habe ich...
Ich habe Instant was gefunden.
Da kannst du nichts machen, es ist zu viel.
Wenn du Hazard-Zone suchst...
Ja, Hazard-Zone könnte tatsächlich schwer werden.
Hazard-Zone ist halt auch...
Dead-Modus. Okay, wir haben verloren.
Aber zum Schluss...
Zum Schluss ging es ja.
Sag mal, what the fuck?
Was ist denn das hier?
0-7-Sniper.
Und der ist auf Platz 4.
Was zum Teufel haben die gemacht?
Die ganze Runde.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist das?
Das sind eh die geilsten, gell?
0-7.
Aber Sniper-Spiel.
Und sauviele Assists. Ja, typische Sniper,
die nichts treffen können.
It's a Sniper.
Das hat der Typ...
Das haben die in BC2 immer rumgeschrien.
It's a Sniper.
Was haben wir denn hier freigeschaltet?
Warhawk-Kompensator.
Wisst ihr, was richtig Six-Head wäre, Leute?
Wenn man hier bei den Unlocks sehen würde,
was es macht.
Aber das war nicht im Scope.
Ich meine, was interessiert mich Attachments,
wenn ich nicht sehe, was sie machen?
Ihr versteht?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Recoil-Control-Weapon.
Die Techno...
Oh nein!
Die schlechteste von allen.
Our Class.
Aber wenigstens sind wir Attacker.
Wenigstens sind wir Attacker, Leute.
Okay, let's go.
Attacker Our Class.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten.
Ihr werdet sehen, zweite Base ist einfach so...
Blessed mit Cover.
Du musst halt einfach durch Wüste laufen,
wo gar nichts ist.
Manch einer wird jetzt sagen,
oh, schöner Realismus.
Hab ich einfach scheiße gemacht.
Railgun-Spiel.
Okay, wir probieren das jetzt mal.
Auf der zweiten Base aber erst,
wenn wir die erste schaffen sollen.
Mit dem neuen Barrel auf der G36.
Für die Bullet Velocity.
Macht das einen Unterschied im Feeling?
Bisschen. Bisschen Unterschied macht es.
What the fuck?
Das ist ja geil,
dass die hier reinschießen können.
Direkt in den Spawn
bist du einfach reingeschossen.
Geilstes Map-Design aller Zeiten.
Nee, wir brauchen den Seilanzer,
wenn wir jetzt hier reingehen.
Okay, Legehände schon am Start.
Nice.
Okay, pass auf, pass auf.
Ich bin überfordert, wo es hier runter geht, Leute.
Wo geht es denn hier runter?
Das ist Schneiber!
Hier war doch irgendwie so eine Treppe, oder?
Hier.
Wow! Alter, der hat
sein Leben abgefarmt hier.
Also, was ich meine ist,
der hat den Kill seines Lebens
hier gerade gemacht. Ich glaube, da kamen gerade acht Leute
oder so die Treppe runter.
Und wurden alle von dem Instant
geschreddert.
Wir müssen eins hoch eigentlich.
Wir müssen eins hoch.
Die kommen von oben, nicht von hier.
Also, hier müssen sie hin, aber
wirklich interessant ist eigentlich nur eins weiter
oben drüber.
Irgendwas ist da hinten doch noch hier.
Ist da noch was? Bestimmt ein Treppenhaus,
hä?
Der Typ ist unter der Treppe, kann das sein?
Haha, ich wusste es,
Alter, dass der Typ unter der Treppe
hockt, Mann.
Fragt man sich, was mit den Leuten falsch ist?
Warum campst du da unter der Treppe ab?
Game ist gecrasht, Keg Wade.
Kannst nachjoinen, dann machen wir ein neues
Squad. Oder nach der Runde.
Vielleicht geht's ja schnell.
So, guckt euch an hier.
Blessed. Komplett blessed mit Cover
hier. Also einfach
astreines Map-Design.
So, vor allem nach dem Hügel
jetzt. Geil, oder? Richtig,
richtig Pog.
Richtig Pog, so. Einfach nichts.
Braucht noch ein paar Sunsacks.
Moment, nicht nur Sunsacks,
ein paar Container wären vielleicht auch noch gut. Gibt's
nämlich zu wenig in dem Spiel. Oh, fuck.
Hieb, willst du mitspielen?
So, du grad da bist. Ein paar Helis,
ein paar
Attack-Runden,
wenn wir Glück haben, dass wir Attack-Runden spielen können.
Probier gerade,
ob OBS mittlerweile geht.
Probier mal.
Eine des Join. Ja, ich bin jetzt, ich hab mich
extra auf Visible gesetzt.
Ich weiß, dass da was auf mich schießt,
aber die sind so PP-ger und treffen eh nicht.
Okay, nice.
Du kannst Join. Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, nach der Runde,
vielleicht müssen wir recoupen nach der Runde,
weil der Captain Poggers ist rausgeflogen.
Au!
Und ohne.
Oh!
No! No!
No!
Alter, was'n Hamper in der Ecke, man.
Huge Aim.
Dead.
Ja, wenn die Runde vorbei ist, geht's los.
Oh, Reiss. Nice, nice.
Spornen.
Den hab ich...
Da oben war doch was, oder?
Alter, was ist mit den Eckensitzern heute los?
Ist ja Wahnsinn.
In jede Ecke hockt einer.
Brrrrrr.
Ich glaube, Dice...
Ich glaube, Dice sollte mich die M-Comb-Effekte
machen lassen.
Oh, shit.
Lassen. Oh shit. Aber wir haben es, wir haben es. Oh, links ist noch irgendwas. Was ist da los?
Einfach so eine hässliche Palme im...
What? Okay, er hat seinen Kill die Runde gemacht hier. Killed by...
Er hat sogar geretzt.
Was, was war, was war das für ein...
Der fuckt mich ab.
Hat er gerade collateral, uns, uns kollateriert im Auto?
So, Spritze in den Sack.
Oh fuck, Alter. PP-Ega-Aim.
Ja, nice.
Oh, Shotgun in die Fresse. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Keck.
Der ist dead. Einfach komplett.
Komplett rip.
Oh.
Jetzt hat die Shotgun wieder kein Damage gemacht.
Die ist so uninkonsistent irgendwie.
Nice, wir haben es.
Sehr gut.
Glaubt ihr, es ist jetzt die letzten M-Comps, die jetzt jetzt kommen?
Die letzten zwei?
Okay, er hat das.
Jawoll.
Let's go, volle Pulle.
Oh, da kommt ein Gegner.
Okay, YOLO-Time.
Geradeaus hier.
Okay, auf die Range ist es halt nix.
Left.
Wir stelzen uns von hinten ran.
Hyper-Gutschi.
Hat er mich doch noch gesehen, die Sau.
Au.
Ich weiß nicht von wo.
Aber ich warte jetzt, bis ihr respawnt.
Max, du kannst bei mir respawnen, klar.
Oh, fuck. Shit.
Shit, shit, shit.
Hab gedacht, das klappt.
Nice.
Vielleicht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass der das überlebt.
Ah.
Jetzt hat er sich wieder hier
einen abgefarmt.
Hätte er klappen können. Hätte er klappen können.
Der lebt noch, der Dude.
Der Max macht es.
Easy.
Pass auf.
Oh, OP.
Absolut OP.
So ordentliche
Supporter zu haben, ist schon nice.
Okay, ich mach jetzt
ihr, der Objective-Player.
Ja.
Ich bin das
M-Com quasi.
Bis erst mal wieder raus.
Max, soll ich dich einladen?
Bist du wieder da?
Ist dein Game wieder gestartet?
Captain Poggers, wir haben doch erst zwei Runden gespielt.
Okay, let's go.
Ich hoffe, jetzt klappt das.
Ich mach mal kurz die Queue aus.
Wobei, sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
Ja, Max, dann kannst du gleich wieder
reinjoinen jetzt nach der Runde.
Auf. Lass mich raus, Game.
Ja, hopp.
Weiter. So schlimm.
Okay.
Nice, wir sind komplett.
Ich find's auch erstaunlich,
Patrick.
Ich bin auch verwundert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Scheint mir grad halbwegs Bock zu machen.
Das Schlimme ist,
wisst ihr, was wirklich das Schlimme daran ist?
Da sieht man, dass egal,
wie verkackt
Battlefield wird,
so dieses,
dieser Grundlayer an Battlefield,
der noch drin ist, den kann man trotzdem
noch ein bisschen spielen.
Überlegt euch mal, würden die diese
gute Base benutzen,
um da auch noch ein wirklich
gutes Game zu machen?
Alter, das könnte auch im Jahr 2023,
2024, 2025 noch gut ankommen.
Hast du Battlebit ausprobiert?
Ja?
Den letzten Playtest?
Ich hab jetzt gehört, dass sich seit dem letzten Playtest nicht mal so viel
geändert hat, aber ja, hab ich.
Spearhead, Attacker!
Jawoll! Easy, Leute.
Jetzt, easy. Wir rushen
die jetzt komplett
um. Throwing Knife.
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, kein Throwing Knife. Wir wollen's ja mal nicht
übertreiben. Jetzt.
Ultra Rush.
Ich glaub, Heap gibt,
hier gibt's kein Heli, oder? Gibt's hier einen Heli?
Dann haben wir schon
instant gewonnen.
Ich glaub, es gibt hier nur auf Conquest und auf
Breakthrough einen Heli. Ich glaub, auf Rush gibt's keinen Heli.
Äh, Sekunde, wir brauchen
das da, das da, das da.
Excellent.
Volle Pulle. Jawoll!
YOLO!
Alter, wir sind unverwundbar, Leute.
Wir sind unverwundbar.
Gag!
Wir sind einfach,
wir konnten einfach nicht sterben gerade.
Unmöglich zu sterben.
Oh, fuck. Bunnyhop
hat nicht funktioniert.
Äh.
Wo ist denn hier was? Ich seh nix.
Ah.
Okay, nice.
Volle Pulle. Oh, das
ist sehr offensiv hier.
Ich bin eigentlich, eigentlich müsste ich
dead sein.
Eigentlich müsste ich dead sein.
Aber ich bin nicht
dead. Warum nicht?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen bin ich nicht dead.
Ah.
Oh, da oben!
Auf der Kiste.
Okay, alle dead.
Das war vielleicht, das war vielleicht
ein bisschen zu optimistisch gerade unser,
unser Garage hier.
Nein! Alter, Game!
Ich wollte gerade...
Ich wollte mich gerade
rumdrehen, da hat das Game gesagt, nope.
Es wird sich nicht umgedreht.
Umdrehen ist
op.
Es wird nicht geturnt.
Ah, man.
Die ist nicht funktioniert.
Mit dem Granat!
Alter!
Der Major schlumpft across the map
mit irgendwelchen Random Nades, ja?
Irgendwie
sonst wie, wow!
Sonst wie in die Richtung gerotzt.
Hehe.
Okay, wir müssen
schnell sein.
Wir spotten mal random
irgendwie in die Richtung.
Okay.
Vielleicht hab ich ja Glück, da rennen ein paar Medics rum.
Nee, dead. Oder? Oder?
Max, pass auf, hier sind ganz schön
viele Leute drin.
Vielleicht, vielleicht haben wir ja Glück.
Ah, op, op, op.
Alles danke.
Hä? Ich hätte wetten können, aus der Ecke
hat gerade jemand geschossen.
Ah, scheiß Kiste!
Ich glaube, wir kriegen das nicht, oder?
Kriegen wir das?
Dowser! Alter, Dowser ist so dumm!
Der Held, man.
Oh, die retzen gerade. Achtung, Achtung, Leute.
Ich respawne, ich respawne.
Hat keinen Sinn.
Da ist, da ist
Spawn.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch gerade. Das ist zu viel für mein Boomer-Hirn.
Ich check nicht mehr, wo hier was
abgeht.
Oh, Massive Kill.
Poggers flank.
Poggers flank, Leute.
Wow!
Da könnten jetzt ein paar sein, von uns.
Wir machen jetzt CS.
CS ist dahin, die Smoke ballern.
Moment, das M-Com ist ja gar nicht mehr hier.
War das M-Com nicht früher auf der Seite?
Ich bin äußerst, äußerst
verwirrt gerade.
Hieb, ich hole dich.
Ich bin gleich da.
Das ist jetzt gerade aber schon, da geht ordentlich
was ab.
Das überfordert mein
39, fast
39-jähriges Hirn.
Aber das ist jetzt mal richtiges
Battlefield-Feeling gerade.
Fuck, hätte ich besser geaimt,
hätte ich den locker geklickt.
Der hat auch nicht getroffen.
Dozer.
Ey, der Schild-Typ, gell?
Der Schild,
das ist so OP.
Jetzt machen wir.
Jetzt pass auf, jetzt machen wir 5-Hit-Play.
Only high IQ.
You can't guess
what happens next.
Ich steh einfach mal
drauf.
Okay, ich würde gerne da hoch.
Das ist mittlerweile die letzte Base,
glaube ich, gell?
Jawoll.
Ja, also diese
Runde sind wir wirklich wie
Butter durch.
Da war ja nichts, da konnte ja wirklich
nichts gehauen. 17 Revives.
Revive war
verbuggt. Also du meinst
quasi, es funktioniert wie immer in dem Game.
Alles beim Halten.
War unter der Map.
Es wundert mich nichts mehr hier.
Okay, Präge
für gute Map und Attacker.
Einmal alle, please, Präge
in den Chat.
Wir brauchen jetzt, oder, oder,
alternativ Gif-Energy.
Das wird so selten verwendet.
Energy ist auch okay. Präge, Präge.
Ihr seid dran schuld, wenn es
nicht klappt, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie Defender
auf irgendeiner Kack-Map wären.
Weil keiner Präge, Präge, Präge,
Präget.
Okay, es hat schon mal geholfen.
Es hat schon mal geholfen.
Es ist eine gute Map, aber
Defender.
Also teilweise, teilweise
Präge. Teilweise Präge
Success.
Das ist auch,
das ist auch ein bescheuerter Satz, oder?
Teilweise Präge Success.
Versteht niemand.
Selbst auf Twitch versteht man das normalerweise
nicht, außer exakt in diesem Zusammenhang.
Also merkt euch, teilweise Präge Success.
Moin.
Wir könnten mal wieder eine andere Waffe spielen.
Wir haben jetzt die letzten Runden immer Kack, Kack,
Kack W36 gespielt.
Lass mal was anderes ausprobieren,
Kleine. Was hat letztens jemand
erzählt? Die TAR ist die neue
Meta-Waffe.
Ich mochte, mir hat die nicht so gut gefallen.
Ich mochte irgendwie das Handling
nicht von dem Ding. Vielleicht braucht man auch irgendwie
das passende Attachment.
Au.
Oh shit.
Siehste, das dumme war, dass mich dieses
doofe Feuer gehittet hat gerade.
Oh, oh, oh,
Achtung, Achtung.
Oh, Gneisares.
Orgasrets.
Achtung, da kommt
jetzt einiges gleich.
Alter, fuck, man, wie
dumm. Ich habe aufgehört zu schießen.
Richtig, richtig
hängen geblieben.
Aber hier, oh, Bowser,
Bowser.
Das ist so OP, das
Kackding, Alter.
Da kam gerade noch einer, ich habe es gesehen.
Granat zu.
Okay, wo sind sie, wo sind sie, wo sind sie?
Oh, ich höre gerade 30
Milliarden Gegner.
Das war nur einer. Alter, das waren 50
Gegner. Passt mal auf, YOLO.
Guckt euch das mal an jetzt.
Scheiße von der Seite.
Oh, das hätte so den krassen
Ultra-Hyper-Kill gegeben,
wenn ich um die Ecke geslidet wäre und einfach in die
Reihe der 8 Gegner hätten reinballern können.
Aber gab es nicht.
War einer an der Seite. Na gut, Pech gehabt.
Piep, moin, gleich da.
Okay.
Max, ich probiere es.
Was, lege Hände?
Ich glaube,
so ist das auch nicht gedacht, oder?
Das ist ja das
Spawnrape des Jahrhunderts, Alter,
was hier abgeht.
Das Spawnrape des
Jahrtausends, Mann.
Guckt euch das, guckt euch
das auf der Map mal an.
Die kommen ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr raus.
Ich würde nicht sagen,
dass es GGEs
knappe Runde ist.
Oh, siehe.
Sehr, sehr...
Okay, wir können nur hoffen,
dass wir Attacker sind.
Mega faire Runde.
Die haben auch schon aufgegeben, ne?
Die haben schon aufgegeben, glaube ich.
Wie, sterben wir jetzt?
Ne.
Der versucht doch jetzt bestimmt zu flanken, oder so.
Pass mal auf.
So.
Okay, das war ja
an Fairness kaum zu überbieten.
Nice.
So muss das sein.
Ab und zu braucht man auch mal Easy Clap Runden.
Ist das Reinhardt aus Overwatch?
Ja, Eichenwald ist da hinten in der Ecke
irgendwo. So von der Wüste
geht es dann direkt rein.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Wobei, Moment, das eine ist Activision, das andere ist EA.
Ne, das geht natürlich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt nicht geguckt,
hattest du, hattest du,
irgendwie Gegner spotted
als besondere Erwähnung, oder?
50.
4 zu 10.
Der erste im Gegner-Team.
Okay, die haben
richtig krass auf den Sarg gekriegt,
Alter.
4 zu 10, der erste, Mann.
Okay, was,
was macht diese
Collection?
Was macht das Teil?
Minimap Stealth,
40 Meter, ist doch genau das gleiche wie das, oder?
Äh,
ist doch mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche.
Achso, ein bisschen anders verteilt.
Und was haben wir noch?
Caspian Box, schon wieder
Defender, Mann. Was ist denn hier
los? Aber hieb, hier kannst du Heli
fliegen. Rapt hat keinen
Schadensabfall.
Ist das verbuggt? Und, und was
ist... Ah ne, ne, Rapt
Suppressor habe ich doch schon.
Achso. Äh, ich, ich
gammel mal kurz. Ne, wir, wir haben...
Äh, ich muss, ich muss gleich,
ich, ich geh gleich auf Anti-Anti-Air
gammeln.
Bin grad mit dem Falschen reingespawned.
Mal gucken.
Mal schauen, wie das jetzt, wie das wird.
Ah, ich mein, 333
FPS, gute Zahl.
Nicht, dass es irgendwie Sinn machen würde,
aber... Schieß ein paar
Bam.
Ich war einfach deadge.
Chats
sacken halt richtig.
Warum sind Chats in dem Teil eigentlich so
mies? Okay, hier müssen
wir gucken. Die springen
jetzt ja hier raus. Dann der erste.
Guck hier,
die sind schon alle am rausjumpen.
Bin mir unschlüssig, bisschen unschlüssig, wo
er hin ist. Okay.
Nice.
Hä?
Ja gut, das ist eh.
Nice, durchgeflogen.
Äh, ist nix.
Dann hab ich da hoch.
Oh, nicht im Scope.
Okay, da müssen wir rüber jetzt.
Der eine ist runtergefallen.
Nice.
Ich, ich fürchte, die kommen wieder nicht ran.
Nicht mal ansatzweise.
Ist der Heli dead?
Lohnt sich das Game mittlerweile zu kaufen?
Für den Vollpreis auf keinen Fall.
Wenn du es im Sale kriegst
Wenn du es im Sale kriegst und du unbedingt
so ein bisschen deine Battlefield
äh
Deine runden Battlefield wieder brauchst
Im Sale
so für 20 oder 15
Euro oder so kann man sich das mal überlegen.
Die Schneiber!
Schneiber!
Schneiber! Schneiber!
Schneiber! Treff mich!
Oh.
Ja, so für 15 Euro
oder so. Ja, ist okay.
Guck mal, wieder easy win.
Die kommen noch nicht mal in die M-Comps
auch nur ansatzweise ran.
Wow.
Du hast letzte Woche mal wieder Battlefield 4
reingegauen. Ja, das ist ja im Vergleich
zu 2042, oh du Scam.
Was?
Diffuse-Gear.
Oh, da war ein Gegner drin.
Shit.
Damit hab ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Alter!
Jetzt lass mich mal in Ruhe.
Ne, ne, ihr müsst nicht diffusen.
Ihr müsst mich gar nicht retzen. Wir haben ja unendlich
Respawn als...
Okay.
Oh, shit, shit, da ist ein Gegner.
Alter, die sind alle immer instant
dead.
Alle instant dead. Du guckst um die Ecke, bam,
tot, bam, tot.
Gleich wieder alle dead.
Ich hol euch.
Okay, lebt schon.
Guck mal, die haben schon keinen Bock mehr.
Au.
Ey.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Die haben schon keinen Bock mehr.
Die haben schon aufgegeben.
Das ist Caspian Border, ja, die haben viele Maps
importiert aus alten Teilen, du hast
Caspian Border, Noshar Cannel,
Valparaiso, Arika Harbor.
Das hab ich nur noch vergessen, Chat. Gibt's noch mehr?
Die könnten nach...
Also, wenn's nach mir geht, könnten die einfach
alles aus alten Teilen importieren.
Versteh gar nicht, warum sie das nicht schon gemacht haben.
Alles. Die könnten komplett
Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4 importieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum sie das
nicht gemacht haben, weil
die Maps, die sie drinnen haben,
sind ja auch noch sehr halbherzig drinnen.
Also, du hast Attacker Boat, Respawns
auf Noshar Cannel hast du Probleme.
Du hast, oh, wow, wow, wow.
Du hast, ähm,
Valparaiso, wo du nicht durchschießen kannst und sowas.
Oh nee, ernsthaft?
Jetzt. Sag mal, wollte er gerade sich
kamikazen ins M kommen und uns
killen?
Hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Der wollte quasi
diffuse
verhindern.
Oh, shit.
Ich auch, ich auch.
Also jetzt nicht in neu,
in dem Sinn, dass man
sagen würde, also wenn das Spiel
jetzt nochmal rauskommen würde,
also wenn es jetzt 2007 oder so wär,
dass es quasi ein neues Game,
weil nochmal würde ich das auch nicht
bezahlen dafür.
Also ihr wisst, wie ich meine, wenn es jetzt halt quasi
als neues Game rauskommen würde.
Easy, easy Runde wieder.
Und vor allem hatte Battlefield 3
halt auch einen richtig großen Umfang,
so auch mit den ganzen DLCs und sowas.
Also mehr als das Spiel
jetzt.
Hier, und das war ein Service
Game, dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Service Game.
Viel Service war bei dem Service Game jetzt ja nicht.
Sagen wir es mal so,
der Service hielt sich in Grenzen, ja.
Ja, Battlefield 3
hab ich lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Ich glaube Battlefield, also die letzten Rush
Server in Battlefield 3, die ich gesehen hab,
die waren
24-7
Demerven Peak und so.
Übrigens auch eine Map, die sie reinpatchen
könnten. Defender!
Alter, was ist denn heute los?
Warum sind wir immer Defender?
Easy Mode Defender
auf der Map.
Ich will mal Attacker spielen, dass Heap Heli
spielen kann und wir alles zerficken.
Letzte Runde.
Ich weiß noch, die letzte Attacker Runde, die wir gespielt haben
auf Arica Harbor, da hatten wir irgendwie 60
Kills jeder.
Die haben wir so krass zerstört.
So, ich mach mal ein bisschen Heli geiern.
Wen haben wir da zur Auswahl?
Engineer?
Boris!
Ich glaube, ich hab noch nie Boris gespielt.
Ich hab schon was anderes ausgewählt.
Der Heli ist
tot? Warum ist der Heli schon tot?
Warum ist der Heli tot?
Kann man den...
Ach, mit der Rakete!
Ach, du meinst, weil du den aus dem Spawn schießen kannst
oder wie?
Also kannst du quasi, wenn du weißt, wo du hinschießen musst,
kannst du den quasi auf dem Flugzeugträger killen.
Oh man, das ist so undurchdacht,
unfertig, pipega
alles von denen.
Oh, das hat gut reingehauen.
Hol dich.
Wo?
Ich seh hier überhaupt nix.
So, und jetzt gibt's halt ein Problem,
Leute, auf der Map.
Die Attackerboote
respawnen nicht richtig.
Was halt echt
so ein Arsch ist. Die Attacker haben jetzt eigentlich schon verloren
und keine Chance mehr.
Ich glaub, es ist zu weit.
Ich muss mal kurz an den Heli ran.
Der Heli ist auch dead.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, okay.
Jetzt den Spawn...
Den Hubs fliegen, den Heli...
Kann man eigentlich noch hier
Attack-Helis so hijacken,
irgendwie? Also dass man, wenn die landen
und so, kann man da noch rein oder ist das alles
nicht mehr möglich?
Kommt selten vor in dem Game.
Lul.
So, wo seid ihr, Leute?
Wo seid ihr?
Au!
Alter, da liegt er.
Die Runde
ist halt schon wieder durch.
Das ist eigentlich nur noch hier
bisschen rumhampeln.
Da, guck mal, was ist denn da?
Nice, ich würde gerne
hier weg.
Ich würde gerne weg.
Okay, dead.
Ich wollte den gerade mit meiner...
mit meinem Grappling-Hook...
Nice, konsistente Shotgun.
Hier werde ich jetzt
den Rest der Runde verbringen.
Ich bleibe jetzt auf dem Dach stehen
und camp auf dem Dach einfach rein, ab.
Wir könnten im Zweifelsfall
die Base nur noch verlieren, wenn irgendwie direkt hier
einer droppt und M-Com legt.
Wirst nicht die Fuze kriegen und so.
Die haben schon aufgegeben, zu Recht.
Du kannst halt auch einfach nicht gewinnen als Attacker,
wenn die ersten Pushes fehlen und die Leute nicht mehr
am Strand sind.
Es ist halt schon ein bisschen lächerlich,
ne?
Dass man eine Map importiert und
und es nicht gefixt kriegt.
Ne, das...
Ja, die Map war auch schon immer in Rush.
Ist nicht so wahnsinnig geil.
Aber die Boote respawnen nicht richtig.
Guck, hast du auch am Anfang
der Runde dein Attacker-Boot gesehen?
Nö, gibt's nicht.
Also das Boot, nicht den Enemy.
Also das ist einfach
unplayable kaputt.
Und ich versteh nicht, dass die das
halt so wenig juckt.
Die importieren die Map, machen die in die normale
Playlist und lassen die einfach Wochen
und Monate verbuggt.
Was ist da los mit euch?
Nice.
Der erste Punkt war mit den Booten scheiße,
aber du hattest wenigstens ne Möglichkeit,
wenn die erste Attack-Welle weg war.
Oder du brauchst halt einen guten Helipilot.
Ich hab auch nicht viel gesehen,
die Runde.
Die Runden sind vorbei, weil wir die immer entweder
komplett überrennen gerade oder
erste Base-Defense.
Das ist Realismus. Ist ein Boot kaputt,
bleibt es kaputt. Ach so.
Wobei ich hab gehört, in Schweden gibt's viele Boote.
Also die müssten da doch irgendwie eins rankriegen.
FPS kriegst du mit
Perf Overlay
Draw FPS 1
In der Konsole.
Oh.
Endlich.
Jetzt kann ich mir ganz tolle Sachen
kaufen in dem Game.
Guck mal, ich kann zum Beispiel
Jawoll!
Epic Hand Cannon
Dings hier.
Anhänger. Charme.
Woah, den brauch ich.
Bullshit, Alter.
Manifest Attacker!
Jawoll!
Attacker mal wieder.
Mach Twitter-Post davon.
Nee, Twitter-Post müsste ich daraus
machen mit nem GIF, wenn
ich das aus irgendeiner Kiste
gezogen hätte.
By the way, es ist vielleicht aufgefallen,
ich stelle weder Skins ein, noch
Waffenskins, noch
Operator-Skins.
Ich spiel einfach irgendwas, was ich mal ausgewählt habe.
Oh, ein bisschen was anderes.
Mach TikTok-Video.
Der erste
Battlefield-TikTok-Influencer.
Okay.
Äh, okay.
Alter, Pepega Aimed ist
Todes, Mann! Das ist Todes
Pepega Aimed.
Lol.
Ich hätte fünf Leute killen können, ne?
Einmal Scheibenwischer.
Hast du mal Battle Bit Remastered
ausprobiert? Ja, hab ich.
Den letzten Public Play
Test hab ich ausprobiert.
Den letzten Public Play Test
und ich hab den großen Battlefield-Killer
noch nicht daraus erkannt.
Da oben war doch einer, oder?
Okay. Ich hol dich
Max, gleich. Du bist der Nächste.
Gibt's Battlelog noch? Nee.
Kein Battlelog mehr. Das war zu gut.
Battlelog. Da konntest du
Leute einladen und konntest Statistiken
angucken und sowas.
Das war nicht gewollt.
Alter, what the
fuck, Game?
Ich seh doch den Kopf von dem Dude rausgucken,
Mann. Achso, ja,
Battlelog gibt es für die alten Teile.
Ja, achso meintest du das. Ja, das gibt es noch.
Aber gibt's halt
für die letzten
fünf neuen Teile und so schon nicht mehr.
BTF, seht ihr, wie das
durchfliegt teilweise? Das ist ja richtig
Pepega Shit, Alter.
Oh, shit.
Da kriegen wir nichts mehr.
Ja,
Battlelog war richtig cool.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich mochte Battlelog
erst mal nicht.
Aber, das war
einfach, weil ich so ein Gewohnheitstier bin
und dachte, Spiele brauchen
Ingame Menüs, ohne Ingame Menüs
sagt. Dabei ist Battlelog
wirklich extrem nice gewesen.
Aber Statistiken
waren nice, ja.
Aber ich finde die Map eigentlich ganz gut.
Leider sind die neuen M-Comps
im Prinzip noch schlechter gewesen
als die, ja, alles klar,
als die letzten.
Leider.
Okay, Yolo,
Yolo.
Da blickst du ja dann durch.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir uns anstrengen.
Wow, Alter.
What the f...
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Statistiken? Wer das verboten hat,
ganz einfach, die ganzen
Ultra-Casual-Noobs,
die das kacke finden.
What the f...
Alter, wo?
Oh, wie PP gar gespielt, Max.
Fuck it.
Warum ist mein Grappling-Hook nicht ready?
Okay.
Nix da.
Alles weg.
Hab den
Splattern sehen, da hinten, den Kerl.
Okay, Yolo, Yolo.
Au.
Oh, K.S., Alter.
Oh, Grand
Bazaar hätte ich richtig Bock
drauf.
Grand Bazaar wäre jetzt Bock.
Auf so eine Runde Grand Bazaar
hätte ich richtig Bock.
Massive Bock hätte ich da drauf.
Alter, wie PP
geaimt. Oh Gott, wie schlecht.
Hat der das gesehen?
Oh Mann, war das mies, Alter.
Au, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
Usas
Fragrance. Ja.
Da erinnere ich mich auch noch dran
mit Schrecken.
So, jetzt muss ich mich mal anstrengen.
Wir müssen jetzt mal Easy Win machen gleich.
Was ist denn hier?
Erstmal noch alles voll smoken.
Und jetzt, zack.
Oh.
Isse.
Oh, oh, oh.
Shit.
Terran Highway, auch
extrem geile Map, ja. Richtig geile
Maps, ja.
Massive Maps.
Ich würde, ehrlich gesagt, wahrscheinlich,
und ich mochte schon die Battlefield 4
Rush Maps nicht sonderlich, ja.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich
jede Battlefield 4 Rush Map
in Base Maps in Battlefield 2042
vorziehen. Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Äh, Fire...
Alter, jetzt ist ja mal gut, Mann.
Firestorm nicht
um... Ja, doch. Sogar, sogar
Firestorm. Firestorm mochte ich nicht.
Ja, theoretisch sogar
Firestorm.
Oh, fuck. Disabled. Wir haben noch 16
Tickets. Wollt ihr mir sagen, wir verlieren das?
Wir können das nicht verlieren.
Easy Win.
Easyest Wins jetzt.
Fucking hell, Alter.
Okay, wir haben
Legehennen gemacht.
Okay, schnell, schnell rein.
Easy, easy, easy.
Haben wir es?
Ich glaube, wir haben es, ne?
Nice.
Boah. Alter, das war
close. Das war close.
By the way, ich finde übrigens auch
diese Grappling Hook-Geschichte und so, ne?
Das passt
einfach nicht zu Battlefield.
Seriously, ich finde das...
Ich finde, das passt einfach nicht.
Ich meine, ich spiele das, weil das mega, mega stark ist.
Und warum soll ich das nicht machen?
Aber ehrlich gesagt,
ich finde, es passt nicht zu Battlefield.
Meiner persönlichen Ansicht nach.
Du musst hier
Grappling Hook-Shit spielen.
Oh, da ist noch einer.
Vielleicht...
Oh, ne, ne. Mach den platt. Jawohl.
Perfekt.
Es sieht gerade relativ clear aus.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, OP.
OP-Teammates.
Okay, was ist da hinten?
Was ist da hinten?
Waren die Diffuse-gegleich?
Nice.
Easy win.
Battlefield Mobile hatte einfach
bessere Maps, mehr Zerstörung, normale Klasse
und mehr Waffen. So traurig das...
Hatte Battlefield Mobile nicht
irgendwie auch nur Maps aus
Battlefield 2 quasi
gerippt?
Was jetzt nicht schlecht ist, weil es hat gute Maps.
Es hatte Grand Pass.
Es hatte auch Karkant.
Es hatte
Sharky. Das hatte, glaube ich, vieles, oder?
Ja, okay, und es hatte Battlefield
3.
Das war so ein Best Of. Ich verstehe gar nicht,
warum die das eingestellt haben.
Ich dachte immer, das war so
semi... War eigentlich recht erfolgreich.
Also, wenn ich so
überlege, ich glaube,
also meine Lieblings...
Also, es ist schwierig zu sagen, was meine Lieblings
Rush-Map überhaupt ist.
Ich mochte in
BC2, fand ich...
Also, Valparaiso
war geil, Port Walders.
Port Walders war meine persönliche Lieblings-Map.
Ich fand das so geil, wie man gelandet ist, quasi
am Anfang mit dem...
vom Flugzeug raus
gedroppt, dann runter in die Base,
dann weiter und am Ende den Berg hoch.
War einfach mega, mega geil.
Also, Port Walders war so mein Geheimtipp, BC2.
BC1?
Pfff, leicht.
Harvest Day, wenn man auf Fahrzeuge stand.
Gerade Harvest Day am Ende
war auch geil mit den Häusern.
BC3 würde ich
sagen, Demavent Peak.
Äh, nicht BC3, BF3.
Demavent Peak war schon eine richtig geile
Rush-Map. Ich behaupte mal,
einen
erinnerungswürdigeren Moment
wie den Jump
vom Damm.
Demavent Peak haben sie nie wieder hinbekommen,
in Battlefield.
Das war einfach so eine geile Idee.
Die planten wieder, bevor wir
da sind.
Bei Pepega-Map-Design.
Und dann,
ich weiß nicht, ich kann einfach nicht glauben,
dass es die gleichen Leute sind.
Na, das wollte ich jetzt nicht.
Das stimmt ja nicht mal, was ich sage. Es sind ja nicht die gleichen Leute.
Es ist doch das gleiche Entwicklerstudio,
aber ohne die gleichen Leute.
Weil die gleichen Leute hätten halt gescheites Game gemacht.
Und, wenn man sie halt,
wenn man sie halt gelassen hätte.
Ich glaube, viele sind halt auch damals weg.
Spätestens seit Battlefield 1 dann.
What the fuck?
Können wir mal ein Diffuse-Skill machen?
Okay, nice.
Wow, wow.
Im Moment, die haben wirklich
die Legehände durchgekriegt auf der Seite.
Ich fasse es nicht, Alter.
Shit, es sind da viele.
Fuck, da standen fünf Gegner in der Ecke.
Okay, wir sind sehr,
sehr optimistisch unterwegs gerade.
Sind die alle dead?
Moment, Moment, höre ich da gerade
außen was?
Oh, der hat in die Fresse gekriegt.
Der hat in die Fresse
gekriegt gerade.
Wieder CS-Pro
im Kopf geaimt gerade.
Shit.
Nein.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig, wo die langgehen gerade.
Okay, Leute,
ich komme zu euch rüber.
Wir sollten zusammen sticken im Squad.
Macht's doch.
Oh, oh, oh, da pusht was durch.
Nice.
Aber instant gerest.
Erst nicht getroffen.
Ich merke da halt immer,
dass mir einfach die Übung fehlt.
Zu 80%,
easy.
Und immer in den angespannten Situationen
ist PP gar
angesagt.
Das Problem ist,
dass ich das Game nicht üben will.
Also, ich spiele das ab und zu mal ein paar Runden,
dann ist gut.
Außerdem, Leute,
außerdem bin ich 39 mittlerweile.
Da muss man auch nicht mehr so OP sein.
Okay, probieren wir mal.
Oh, das war jetzt
eine blöde Idee.
Fuck, Alter.
Shit.
Aber das war ein
nices Grappling-Movement,
müsste ich sagen.
Oh, ich höre
hier einiges gerade.
Oh, ich glaube, da ist auch was durch.
Okay, YOLO-Modus.
Nice.
Heap hat's gecarried alleine.
Kein Ding. Nice.
Eats.
Stell dir vor, wenn sie Dämmerwend-Peak gebracht hätten
und man würde herunterspringen,
gäbe es eine unsichtbare Wand, wo alle dranstehen.
Das wird jetzt noch
drin sein, ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, es ist immer noch...
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, ja.
Die hatten in einem First-Person-Shooter
nach einem Patch
einen Bug.
Und zwar, dass die Maus nicht mehr ging.
Das muss man sich auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen.
Du konntest nicht mehr gucken
im First-Person-Shooter-Game.
Und wisst ihr, was sie gemacht haben,
um das zu fixen?
Wisst ihr, was sie gemacht haben?
Dramatische Pause. Wisst ihr, was sie gemacht haben?
Die haben
nix gemacht.
Nix.
Die haben es nicht gefixt.
Was die Leute machen mussten ist,
die mussten auf die Hilfe-Seite von EA gehen,
in den Settings-Folder
navigieren und
ihr Settings-File im Settings-Folder
löschen, dass es wieder ging.
Die haben es nicht gepatcht.
Normalerweise muss sowas beim
bemerken... Ich meine, das ist ein
First-Person-Shooter, in dem du nicht gucken
kannst.
Das ist ein First-Person-Shooter,
in dem die First-Person nicht funktioniert.
Die haben es einfach nicht gefixt.
Die haben nichts gemacht.
Normalerweise muss sowas hotfixed
werden.
Innerhalb der ersten Viertelstunde
übertrieben gesagt, ja?
Aber es reicht ja auch.
Leute, wir müssen... Guck mal.
Wir brauchen ja eigentlich
gar keinen Maus-Look.
Wir können einfach WASD aimen.
Oder einfach
Controller spielen. Easy.
Das ist schon ziemlich fail.
Battlebit.
Ich habe es schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Battlebit habe ich
den letzten
Public Playtest gespielt.
Ich habe ja nichts
gegen minimalistischen
Grafikstil.
Wir können einfach WASD aimen.
Leute, guckt mal. Wozu braucht man ein Maus?
Wir spielen einfach
nur Pfeiltasten.
Pfeiltasten und WASD.
Wie schießt man überhaupt?
Wie schießt man ohne Maus?
Hahaha.
Wie zum Teufel.
Wie soll man sowas spielen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ich weiß nicht.
Oh, mit CTRL schießt man.
Okay, pass auf.
Okay, ich nehme die Maus wieder.
Ich habe es probiert, Leute.
Pfeiltasten hat nicht funktioniert.
Er möge bitte vorwärts fahren.
Fünf Euro, wenn du so einen Kill machst.
Nee, ich will die Runden nicht verlieren.
Was habe ich denn hier?
Öh.
Da ist jetzt doch bestimmt
irgendeiner.
Alter, fuck.
Der Gefreite sitzt hinterm Felsen und hat
klitscht.
Ich habe schon gedacht, da bewegt sich doch ein Fuß
oder so. Aber ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Fuck. Der Gefreite sitzt
im Felsen rum.
Ich hasse diesen
Shell-Typ. Das ist so dumm.
Das ist so dumm.
Okay, das war richtig krass PP geaimt.
Aber so dumm, Alter. So
hängen geblieben.
Aber pass mal auf. Wir machen jetzt hier volle Pulle.
Wir gehen da jetzt
voll rein.
Boris!
Ist das dumm.
Ist das dumm, Alter.
Es ist so
dumm.
Es ist einfach so dumm.
Das Spiel, Alter.
Haha.
Haha. Das ist so
dumm, Mann.
Wie hat der Dude mich
eigentlich gekillt?
Alter, what the hell.
Leute, es ist...
Es geht nicht, dass wir einfach verlieren.
Wir dürfen nicht verlieren.
Verlieren ist nicht im Scope.
Sonst müssen wir jetzt agiles
Daily machen und uns gleich in der Retrospektive
überlegen, warum... Fuck.
Retrospektive, warum wir verloren haben.
Fuck.
Mach mal ein Schild.
Nee.
Wow.
Okay, wir probieren mal was.
Wow, jetzt wirst du voll ins Auge wissen.
Okay, Leute. Wir haben ein Problem.
Wir haben ein Problem.
Die wissen, dass wir da sind.
Das ist problematisch.
Okay, okay. YOLO.
Fuck.
Scheiße, Mann.
In jeder Ecke sitzt da einer.
Ich raste aus.
Battlefield zur Entspannung, wie man hört.
Exzellente Entspannung
ist gerade angesagt.
Exzellent.
Es wird hardcore entspannt gerade.
Boris, du dreckiger Scheiß.
Specialist-Kacke
mit dem Schild, Alter.
Ich finde, man hört das klar,
dass man entspannt.
Alter, das ist so dumm.
Das ist so dumm.
Jawohl, jawohl.
Fucking Scheiß.
Alter.
Wir haben es probiert, Leute.
Ich kann jetzt nicht respawnen.
Wenn ich respawne, ist Dad...
Okay, jetzt kann ich respawnen.
Jetzt kann ich schnell respawnen bei Max.
Okay.
Alter, wie haben wir das geschafft?
Ist Battlefield 2020
mittlerweile gut? Nein.
Nein.
Oh Gott, Alter.
Wie haben wir das denn jetzt geschafft?
Das war jetzt aber echt
auf den
sowas von letzten Drücker.
Monka
S.
Hyper Monka S.
Monka SX
das Monka S.
Moin, Terrorkeks.
Was ist denn hier?
Servus.
Okay, Reds, please. Leute, ich sitze direkt neben euch.
Ah, sehr schön.
Danke.
Ich smoke euch einfach ein.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ich bin mir
unsicher von wo.
Okay, mir darf der nicht hitten. Auch gut, nice.
TRX. Okay, ich push jetzt.
Oh, du musst dich beeilen.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, gut, gut, gut, gut, gut, gut, gut.
Ich, ich, ich, ich
weiß noch nicht mal, wo die überhaupt sind. Sind die alle down?
Ich glaube, die sind alle dead.
Sind die alle dead? Ich glaube, die sind
alle dead.
Hoi, hoi, hoi.
Ah.
Alter, dieser Held ist so
dumm mit dem Schild. So
unglaublich dumm.
Ich bräuchte übrigens mal einen Smoke.
Hier ist ein Smoke
jetzt auch nicht so sinnvoll gewesen.
Weil hier oben sitzen die bestimmten.
Baller mich jetzt von der Seite weg.
Sag ich doch.
Auf, hüpf.
Hüpf.
Jetzt aufs Dach rauf gleich.
Okay, pass auf,
pass auf, pass auf.
Oh Gott, game.
Ich hab da ein bisschen Schiss gerade.
Kack-Sniper-Noob.
Okay, wir probieren was, Leute.
Wir gehen jetzt hier rüber.
Shit. Hab ich nicht gesehen
hinter mir.
Nee, nee, retzt mich nicht.
Ich komm bei euch rein.
Du hast gerade Battlefield Remastered.
Nein, das ist kein Battlefield-Killer.
Hab ich ja am Anfang des Streams schon gesagt.
Also ich hab die letzten Public...
Also der einzige Battlefield-Killer ist DICE.
Wenn es einen Battlefield-Killer gibt,
dann ist es DICE persönlich.
Es ist
vielleicht für manche eine Battlefield-
Alternative. Wobei ich
sagen muss, ich hab ja nichts
gegen minimalistische Grafik.
Aber
der Grafikstil von Battlefield, der hatte
keine Tiefe. Also hatte es auch keine
Details auf den Maps und sowas.
Das hat mir persönlich nicht gut gefallen.
Was ist denn hier los?
Was ist da ohne?
In der Ecke. Der Nico, den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Da hat's Boomer-Hirn wieder ausgesetzt.
Ich hol dich, Max.
Ich hol dich. Zack.
Ah, du wirst schon. Nice.
Du hast recht. Ja, die Beleuchtung
ist außerdem auch so, dass du überhaupt
nicht Tiefen erkennst im Battle-Bit.
Weißt du was ich meine? Also
du weißt, du erkennst manchmal gar nicht, wann der
Gang eigentlich zu Ende ist.
Das ist mies. Also
man könnte
den Grafikstil oder Raytracing
oder sowas, naja, man könnte den
Grafikstil sicherlich cool machen, aber
vielleicht war... Mir hat er nicht so richtig
zugesagt. Und das liegt wohlgemerkt
nicht an der minimalistischen Grafik.
Gar nicht. Also das ist wirklich das Problem.
Leute, ich spiele Spiele seit
1990 oder so.
Ich hab garantiert
nichts gegen minimalistische Grafik.
So.
Wir gehen jetzt aufs
Dach.
Falls es hier noch die Dinger gibt, ja.
Hui!
Drei Stunden.
Seilbahn.
Battlefield Heroes.
War das das mit dem
Comic-Style?
Ah, Moment, ich bin dumm. Hier oben ist ja gar nichts mehr.
Lulve. Alter.
Warte mal, hier ist ja gar nichts mehr.
Okay.
Äh, nice.
Oh, fuck.
Äh, irgendwie, irgendwie sind die alle weg.
Keiner mehr da?
Alle, alle weg?
Easy win?
Hui!
Ich bin mal gespannt,
also sollte sich das wirklich bewahrheiten,
dass
schon 2024
das nächste Battlefield kommen soll, oder zumindest,
sagen wir mal, Ankündigung vielleicht nach 2015.
Und da der Apex
der Apex-Dude
das Sagen hat,
die werden sich sicherlich nicht
in-house Konkurrenz machen, was
Battle Royale angeht. Das glaube ich
nicht.
Auch wenn ein, sagen wir mal,
außerdem ist Battle Royale ja auch schon irgendwie
ausgelutscht. Warzone
war so das letzte richtig große
Mainstream-Battle Royale.
Danach gammelte das alles immer so ein bisschen
vor sich hin. Ich glaube,
Battle Royale ist auch ein bisschen raus.
Jetzt zwischenzeitlich war ja diese
Extraction-Geschichte. Ich glaube,
das ist auch schon so ein bisschen
raus wieder. Also,
wisst ihr, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
das Beste, was sie machen
könnten mit Battlefield 20...
2024, sagen wir mal.
Also, mit dem, was nächstes Jahr eventuell
erscheint, ist einfach...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Hazardsong kann ich nicht spielen.
Da dreh ich durch.
Also vielleicht,
wenn jetzt Defender
auf...
Was ist denn so eine richtige, miese Map?
Discarded oder sowas noch mal
kommt. Also,
Battlefield 5 Stranded
Attacker, beste.
Den gibt's noch, Firestorm, glaube ich. Hat Kleiner gespielt.
Also, wisst ihr, was, glaube ich, das Beste ist,
was sie machen können
in einem neuen Battlefield?
Einfach keinem Hype hinterherrennen.
Man hat gesehen, wozu es geführt hat, hier mit Specialists
und so. Man merkt dem Game an, dass sie
ursprünglich Hazardsong
machen wollten, aber zu unfähig waren
dafür, ein gutes Extraction-
Ding zu bauen.
Weil nur im Kontext von Hazardsong
macht das überhaupt Sinn,
dass es hier Specialists gibt
und sowas. Ja, okay, natürlich auch was
Microtransactions und sowas angeht.
Also, das Beste wäre,
sie rennen keinen neuen Gaming-Hypes
hinterher, sondern konzentrieren sich
einfach drauf, ein Battlefield-
Spiel zu machen. Battlefield
braucht kein Battle Royale oder
Extraction-Modus oder sowas. Battlefield
hat ein einzigartiges
Spielgefühl. Niemand anderes
hat das Battlefield-Spielgefühl.
Es gibt kein Battlefield
außer Battlefield.
Oh, Max ist rausgeflogen.
Die sollen einfach ein Battlefield machen.
Und das wird
erfolgreich sein, wenn das gut ist.
It's game, Alter.
Oh, fuck, das hätte so ein guter
Flank werden können.
Werden die es safe nicht machen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich.
Alter, mein PP-Geheimnis heute, krass, Alter.
Der wurde jetzt
aber komplett destroyed,
der Typ, Alter.
Der wurde
jetzt komplett geblast, gerade
der Typ.
Sector
open is in. Ja.
Okay, wir sind schon durch. Ich rede jetzt dem Heap
einfach mal nach.
Mein Timer wurde gerade nicht angezeigt.
Fucking hell, shit, ich dachte,
der Lenker ist tot. Shit.
Ja, die
haben uns geownt, gerade.
Oh, wir sind schon
dran. Jetzt werden sie
weggeruscht, hier.
Ruschmasters sind
am Start. Max,
ganz schlechte Idee. Die kommen
direkt von hinten.
Äh.
War ich zu früh?
Chatge? Ich dachte,
ich war genau bei 10.
Oder bei 9.
Ich war zu früh, hä?
Oh, nein!
Gutscheepas in Bobbes.
Das ist nicht so mein
Ragequit. Ja.
Okay, Heap ist gerade
Ragequitted, oder? Kann das sein?
Okay, die Runde
machen wir noch. Mir reicht's auch langsam.
Jetzt ist wieder Hardmode.
Unser Hardcarry ist weg.
Ja, nächste Runde.
Nächstes Mal kannst du wieder, wenn du dich
erholt hast.
Gucken, dass wir die Runde noch...
Alter!
Es wäre äußerst nice, wenn die Kugel einfach
hitten würden.
Also, Game, das hätte schon was.
Enormste
Fog!
Wow, wow, wow, ich weiß nicht von wo, aber...
Immer nicht ganz...
Wow, wow, wow, wow!
Ich muss mal kurz campen.
In der Ecke campen.
Okay, nice.
Wo sind die denn?
Ah, das war blöd.
Das war blöd.
Oh, ich hab Hunger. Ich glaube, ich ess was nach der Runde.
Hutke!
Not enough space to deploy.
Okay, dann spawnen wir einfach hier.
Guter Spawnpoint, by the way.
Okay, das ist extra.
Exquisite.
Ja, das hat er sich anders vorgestellt.
Jawohl.
Spawnge...
Da! Warum...
Warum wissen die das die ganze Zeit?
Was ist denn hier los?
Okay, einfach A defenden und easy win.
Oh!
Eats!
Okay.
Nice.
GG.
Reicht für heute.
Drei Stunden Battlefield 2043 ist genug.
Und Chat, was meint ihr?
Ich hab euch jetzt ja meiner Meinung
die ganze Zeit schon öfters mal erzählt.
Was meint ihr?
Lohnt sich das Game für Battlefield-Fans
mittlerweile oder nicht?
Best Game ever.
Nee, find ich auch.
Ich bin ja auch nicht ein big Destroyer.
Zum Glück ist es nicht.
Ja.
Sage ich jetzt nicht,
aber ihr könnt es euch wahrscheinlich denken.
Oh ne! Nein!
Okay.
Wer war denn das? Jemand aus dem Chat?
Jemand von euch, Chat?
Du meinst aber MW2,
der Major Schlumpf. Das ist einer von euch, der ist im Chat.
Du meinst MW2
2022 vermutlich.
Was?
Ich werde jetzt was futtern.
Und dann vielleicht
noch YouTube-mäßig was aufnehmen.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, was ich glaube. Links zu Battlefield.
Einfach durch.
Später Battlefield.
Ich glaube, nochmal drei Stunden schaffe ich heute nicht.
Morgen drei Stunden, jetzt drei Stunden,
nochmal drei Stunden.
Chat, wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
Macht's gut. See you.